- Shit! Shit, shit, shit...
- C'est une question quiérérite
d'être posée à chaque conflit :
jusqu'à quel point faut-il
présenter des images
de la guerre?
Comme cette vid, , qui présente
un homme aspiré par un tir
de mortier à Irpin, en banlieue
de la capitale ukrainienne.
Ou, attention, des images
qui pourraient vous choquer,
comme celle-ci, publiée sur
la page d'acl l l du "New York
Times", où l'on peut voir
une famille, dont deux enfants,
retrouvés morts avec leur
valise, alors qu'ils tentaient
der r r les bombardements
russes.
COLETTE BRIN, professeure de
journalisme à l'Université Laval
- Peut-être que dans le cas
du "New York Times", il y a
cette volonté de faire prendre
conscience que c'est vraiment
un... quelque chose d'une rare
violence.
- La professeure Colette Brin
estime que ce genre de photo
choc permet à la fois
d'illustrer la dure réalité
de la guerre sur le terrain
et aussi de contrecarrer
la désinformation tant chez
les Russes que les Ukrainiens.
- C'est quelque chose qu'il faut
utiliser, qu'il faut pas...
dont il faut pas abuser,
ce genre de photo-là,
parce que ça frappe beaucoup,
puis il faut pas banaliser ce
genre de violence-là non plus.
e e e e nombreuses photos
sont passées à l'histoire,
comme celle qu'on a tristement
surnommée "La petite fille
au Napalm", lors de la guerreduo
du petit Alyan Kurdi, 3 ans,
et d'origine syrienne,
découvert sur une plage turque,
inanimé sur le sable,
face contre terre.
YVANOH DEMERS, photojournaliste,
Radio-Canada
- Alyan Kurdi, il va y en avoir
une qui s'en vient ou qui est
déjà là par rapport à l'Ukraine.
- Le photojournaliste de Radio-
Canada Yvanoh Demevevevevevert
plusieurs crises, que ce soit
en Haïti, en Lybie ou en
Afghanistan. La publication
de photos, même tragiques,
a sa raitrtrtrtrtre, selon lui.
- Les images sont très dures
et il faut les faire, et après
ça, il faut les envoyer,
et il y a toute une chaîne
ioioioioions qui, plus tard,
les gens peuvent décider
s'ils vont les publier ou pas.
Ironiquement, de plus en plus,
les photographes, de toute
façon, mettent les photos
sur leur fil Instagram.
- Et même s'ils sont en petit
nombre sur le terrain,
le travail des reporters
comme des photojournalistesavavl
à l'ère des réseaux sociaux.
Ici Gabrielle Proulx, R R R R a